all right among all the trailers that
have come out lately people were like
dude you got to talk about the
Prometheus trailer and for a trailer
that's only a minute long think there's
enough to talk about here all right so
if you guys don't know Prometheus is
directed by Ridley Scott the director of
alien and originally Prometheus was
gonna be an alien prequel and now Ridley
Scott said it's not actually an alien
prequel anymore it's it's own saga and
its own story he said there's like bits
of alien DNA in it whatever that means I
assume it takes place in the same
universe as the alien movies but it's
not actually an alien prequel you're not
gonna see any alien ish things in it and
if you do it'll be really slight so the
trailer Prometheus just sets the tone in
motion immediately it's creepy as hell I
mean honestly you kidding me with that
you just look at the trailer and you're
like dude that's a total alien movie
trailer the way the letters Prometheus
start appearing on the screen total
alien trailer these little lines come on
the screen and they spell out Prometheus
eventually if you remember the original
alien trailer does the same thing with
the word alien so how can you say it has
nothing to do with the movie alien and
then have the same letter in appear just
like the alien trailer stop playing
games man I don't know maybe it does tie
in to alien but we're not supposed to
know it's gonna be like some big secret
or something that he spilled the beans
years ago about he was like I got a
backtrack okay it doesn't actually tie
into alien some thing it's called
prometheus
and then the trailer starts making that
one sound you know what I'm talking
about
all the cool kids are doing it again
yeah that must be it although it is a
good sound to set up tension so it works
in situations like this and then the
trailer looks like it ends only it
doesn't end the big ship that looks like
a big horseshoes rolling down a hill
trying to kill people when you've pissed
off a ship that looks like the letter U
you know you've made your mark in the
universe everyone knows that don't mess
with them why I think can because no one
really knows so this trailer is straight
up a teaser trailer this is what I'm
used to teaser trailers looking like a
few sounds a few glimpses that
illustrates the tone of the movie and
there you have it as far as I'm
concerned Prometheus looks cool as hell
oh one minute that we see of it so the
Prometheus trailer have you seen it what
did you think of it and what's your
favorite alien movie just curious and
I'd like to thank you all for a really
cool year in 2011 next year it's gonna
be better than the last 2012 dudes gonna
be nuts and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more I'm
gonna do that in my videos just to make
it intense